Joe Biden is not known for his
consistency over the years Joe has
changed his views on just about every
issue Under the Sun from crime to
abortion to foreign policy to marriage
to pretty much everything else
unprincipled politicians such as Joe
Biden sometimes refer to this kind of
flip-flopping as evolving
and now it seems Joe Biden has evolved
into a Puerto Rican I was sort of raised
in the Puerto Rican community at home
politically and so we and we came here
for a long time both for business and
pleasures
Richard Levine is a woman
Elizabeth Warren is an Indian
Joe Biden is a Puerto Rican
and I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show you know it's
amazing actually just I was going to say
I'm the only one who's remained
consistent here everyone else is turning
into something but that's not true last
night I actually was Candace Owens
because Candace was supposed to give a
speech at the University of Delaware and
instead she flew to Paris to
set the internet on fire with Kanye West
and so I I actually okay Joe Biden's a
Puerto Rican Liz Warren's an Indian I'm
Candace Owens my favorite comment
yesterday is from David McAllister who
says I'm so glad YouTube added abortion
context to this video otherwise I would
have just kept believing it was doctors
killing defenseless babies for profit I
I actually had a few other people write
into me about this so in my episode
yesterday
which touched on a ton of subjects
though it did it did mention abortion
and aoc's stupid commentary on abortion
YouTube added a warning a sort of a
context warning and it just shows you
that kovid was not a unique emergency
that required Extraordinary Measures
kovid was a test run for all new sorts
of power grabs by the left because
during covid the libs said well we need
to add warnings about medical
misinformation and the masks and the
social distancing and the vaccines and
so they would add these little these
little context bubbles to our videos to
basically just push the liberal line on
covid and and discourage people from
listening to different points of view
but now covet's over and they're doing
it on topics that that are completely
unrelated to covet now they're doing it
on abortion so I come out and I say yeah
AOC said a dumb thing about abortion
abortion actually is really great and
you shouldn't have any questions about
it it's a it's a perfectly fine medical
procedure and okay right they're gonna
do it they're going to do it with
anytime anyone criticizes Joe Biden
pretty soon actually Joe Biden's a
really great guy and you should not you
should stop insulting him that's not
nice it's great it's crazy I don't think
that people believe that Joe Biden is a
Puerto Rican
I don't think
I don't think people believe Joe Biden
period
I think Joe Biden
is not persuasive and I think the reason
that he and and all the other libs are
not really persuasive is because they
keep being proven wrong
it's the fool me one shame on you fool
me twice shame on me or as George W bush
put it fool me twice the point is you're
not going to fool me again and and with
the libs it's fool me three times fool
me four times fool me five times
covid certainly accelerated that Trend
and so it's just
it's not persuasive especially when you
compare Biden and the Democrats with the
political alternative
you want to talk about persuasive you
want to talk about in charge Ron
DeSantis down there in Florida in uh the
wake of this horrible hurricane that
destroyed so much of Florida killed a
lot of people destroyed a lot of
property at CNN is using this as an
opportunity to really Grill the governor
and make it seem like he's not competent
that this is somehow his fault which of
course is absurd listen to how Ron
DeSantis knocks the CNN reporter down
why do you stand behind Lee County's
decision to not have that mandatory
evacuation until the day before the
storm well did you where was your
industry stationed when the storm hit
were you guys in Lee County no you were
in Tampa so that's you know they were
following the weather track and they had
to make decisions based on that but you
know 72 hours they weren't even in the
cone 48 hours they were on the periphery
so you got to make the decisions the
best you can I will say uh you know they
delivered the message to people they had
shelters open you know everybody had
adequate opportunity to at least get to
a shelter within the county but you know
a lot of the residents did not um did
not want to do that I think for probably
for various reasons some people just
don't want to leave their home period
they're island people whatever but I
think part of it was so much attention
was paid to Tampa that I think a lot of
them probably thought that they wouldn't
get the worst of it so you know they um
but they did it and I think it's uh it's
easy to second-guess them but they were
ready for the whole time and and made
that call when when there was
justifiable to do so by the way this
goes on for about another minute and
DeSantis goes he's just citing facts
he's citing hour-by-hour weather trends
he's pointing out that CNN also thought
that the storm was going to move in a
particular way and then after the storm
shifted then Florida shifted resources
down and so you just you leave that
conversation with the impression
this guy knows what he's doing
okay if they had asked Joe Biden that
question what would he have done he
would have started drooling he would
have started talking about Corn Pop in
the Delaware public pool he would it's
it's not you can't even compare the two
it's not that that Joe Biden might not
have been able to cite all of those
facts Joe Biden wouldn't have known what
state he was in and so when people are
comparing Republican leadership right
now to Democrat leadership it doesn't
take a a political nerd you know someone
following all the trends to see oh the
Republicans basically have their act
together the Democrats have no idea
what's going on you can see this there
was a video that went viral yesterday of
a guy who I don't think he's a political
consultant you know I don't think that
this is a guy who's you know constantly
keeping up refreshing the page on Real
Clear Politics every day he's a regular
Florida Citizen who says look I'm a
Democrat I've always considered myself a
Democrat but DeSantis seems so competent
I'm voting for that guy
y'all but it's here in Arcadia so y'all
know who we vote for
the center and I'm a Democrats
there's just a real persuasive aspect to
competence to just a basic degree of
confidence we tend to think of Politics
as this ideological struggle between the
leftists and the conservatives and the
marxists and the fascists and the
desists and that but for a lot of people
politics comes down to hey are you going
to show up can you just like show up
when bad stuff happens and try to make
it better hey can you reduce crime in my
neighborhood hey can you keep the
economy kind of going along hey can you
fill my potholes fill my potholes
is a really important political
tactic okay fill my potholes goes a long
long way
and and DeSantis is doing it he's doing
it on every single level you even heard
In that clip DeSantis he said you know
there are misleading narratives you guys
are you guys are pushing misleading
narratives and I've noticed that Rhonda
santis I don't know if it was in that
specific look it was it was certainly in
the CNN interview and he keeps coming
back to this misleading narratives why
because misleading narratives is the Ron
DeSantis version of fake news right
Donald Trump says you're fake news Ron
DeSantis is saying the exact same thing
but he uses a synonym because he doesn't
want to just be seen as a copycat of
trump he wants he adopts a lot of
Trump's uh characteristics and habits he
uses the Trump hands the sort of like
New York Italian hands really but he
uses the Trump hands he uses some of the
Trump diction and and Cadence but he
changes it he makes it his own and that
I think that competence goes a long way
especially if DeSantis does choose to
run
in 2024
presidents tend to be the opposite of
their predecessors
right you think of
George W bush go all the way back to
George W bush Bill Clinton is marked by
this kind of liberal skeezy you know
completely irreligious immoral White
House full of Scandal and then George W
Bush whatever you think of the guy he's
a pretty upright man born-again
Christian you know there's there's no no
sex scandals coming out of the George W
bush White House then after Bush what do
we get we get Barack Obama so the Bush's
old white establishment
vaguely conservative Barack Obama young
fresh newcomer leftist first black
president then what do you get after
Obama after Obama who's this young fresh
radical we're gonna fundamentally
transform America we hate the old
America Obama's wife says the first time
I was ever proud of my country was when
it elected my husband what happens you
get Donald Trump who says now we're
bringing back the old America make
America great again right Donald Trump
this older guy kind of more old school
right wing style then after Trump who
was relatively pretty effective actually
even in just one term in office even
with the Deep State trying to undermine
him what do you get you get and this guy
who's a total populist bull in a china
shop upending The Establishment what do
you get you get the most establishment
boring guy in the entire world Joe Biden
so what comes after Biden maybe you get
Trump again
but DeSantis is putting himself in a
position where he could be
a good alternative there's no question
about it and it's not just DeSantis by
the way
you're seeing Republicans around the
country who are showing this kind of
energy and Clarity and competence Kerry
Lake we haven't gotten to talk about her
very much on this show but we absolutely
should Carrie like running for governor
of Arizona listen to how adeptly she
fends off a reporter's dishonest
ridiculous question on abortion
something that you support I support
saving as many lives as possible and
what I really want to know and I've been
waiting I tune into you guys all the
time I want to know where Katie hop
stands but I never hear you guys ask for
that I'm pro-life my plan would be that
every woman who walks into an abortion
clinic know that there are options out
there they don't have to choose them
there's families who would love to adopt
a baby and right now the way it's been
going they go in and they only have one
option nobody tells them that there's
other options we want to help our women
if they're afraid we want to help them
we want to give Women Health Care and I
want to help people but I really
challenge you and I'm happy to get back
to you on this when you find out where
Katie Hobbs stands because let me tell
you where she stands she supports
abortion right up until birth and after
birth that's right she supports if a
baby survives a botched abortion that
that baby die in a cold metal tray and
none of you ever try to get her to talk
about her stance so get back to me after
you do thank you and tell her
fabulous exactly how it's done okay you
carry like obviously is on the right
side of the issue she's on the pro-life
side of the issue but it's not just
about ideology or political views or
or policies even there is a role for
just a basic political competence and we
kind of forget this because we're living
in the Biden era but this woman expertly
flipped this question back on the
reporter this dishonest question said
hold on what you're pushing me on all
this ridiculous kind of these these
cases that barely ever happen that
you're framing the issue from this
ridiculous Place why don't you ever ask
my opponent I'll tell you what you think
she wants to let babies born alive die
in in cold metal trays that's the way to
do it and after such dysfunction and
incompetence for the past couple of
years now I think
voters are hungry for people who can
actually do the job we're not don't just
have the right opinions or the opinions
they prefer but can actually do a job
as the elites prove themselves to be
incompetent
people begin to look elsewhere
people begin to doubt the authority of
these Elites look no further than
the federal bench
federal judge James
see ho who is on the fifth Circuit Court
of Appeals has just said that he will no
longer hire law clerks from Yale Law
School
he's right to do it he says that Yale
law school is not what it once was he
says Yale not only tolerates the
cancellation of views it actively
practices it starting today I will no
longer hire law clerks from Yale law
school and I hope that other judges will
join me as well
he's smart he's smart to say that
some people are complaining well what
about the good kids at Yale law school
yeah maybe but
Yale law school is considered the top
school in the country
Yale law school sends all of its
students out to extremely prestigious
posts if you have Yale law school on
your resume you you can pretty much go
wherever you want
why well because of the prestige and the
tradition and that goes along with that
name but does a Yale law school degree
today
represent what it used to represent 10
20 30 40 years ago
no I don't think it does
the caliber of students who are coming
out of Yale law school is is inferior
today than it was 20 30 40 years ago
the things that they're being taught at
Yale law school are inferior they're
less true they're less good than the
things that they were taught 20 30 40
years ago and so if you're a judge
hiring clerks I think it's perfectly
rational to say you know look I know
this place has a good reputation I know
it's been the top of the Heap for many
years now but it's just decayed okay and
the libs have gone in they've cut it
open they've emptied out the body of
Yale law school like that monster in the
first scene of The Empire Strikes Back
right they've just taken the guts out of
Yale law school and then they've crawled
inside of Yale law school and animated
it like Night of the Living Dead
and they kind of hobble around in it but
it's not it's not actually what it once
was and so I'm gonna stop giving it this
special privilege if we always hire the
yls people and I'm going to start
looking around to other law schools of
course and it's it's not just about law
clerks it's not just about Yale
it used to be again 10 20 30 40 years
ago
that if if you had Harvard Yale
Princeton Stanford these big fancy
schools on your resume that really meant
something and employers really looked
for that is that still true today I'm
not so sure
certainly if if I were hiring people
I would you know maybe I'd say okay
maybe that means you got a decent SAT
score though maybe it doesn't I'm not
even sure I mean the schools for a while
weren't even looking at SATs
and and we're we're not even giving high
priority test CD so it's I I don't even
know that it means you got a basic level
of kind of intelligence forget about if
you know anything or have the right the
right opinions or you know have the
right values or anything like that
but does it does it mean anything
anymore I don't know if I got a resume
today from a kid from Hillsdale and a
kid from Princeton
I I'm probably going to just immediately
suspect that the kid from Hillsdale is
better educated than the kid from
Princeton the kid from Princeton could
surprise me but this would be this would
be an unthinkable opinion 20 years ago
but it just the the the the authorities
the elites can't Coast on their
reputation forever after they have done
their damnedest to destroy that
credibility and to destroy that
reputation
the the clearest example of this is
covid
before covid I generally
believed what the public health
authorities said not a hundred percent
but I I thought okay they probably know
more about epidemics and stuff than I do
so I guess I'll generally follow their
advice I'll generally believe what they
think whether they're talking about
vaccines whether they're talking about
uh epidemics that come around I think I
don't know I don't know anything about
it I guess they probably do so I'll
believe them after kovit I don't believe
a word they say after covet if Dr fauci
came up to me and said we've got an
epidemic coming and you all need to take
this shot and then I had an African
Shaman witch doctor come to me and say
actually we just need to boil three
kidneys of goat in the eye of Newt and
then then the pandemic will pass I will
believe the African witch doctor Shaman
I think he's got more medical
credibility than Dr fauci after these
people in our Public Health
establishment have lied to us and
intentionally deceived us and
furthermore when they weren't
intentionally deceiving us just were
completely incompetent and made stupid
errors and got things wrong on going all
the way back to the origin of the virus
by the way
so they've they've squandered their
credibility they continue to squander it
by the way by the way I don't know if
you caught this this doozy of a headline
so
there's a new new report out new
scientific medical report an mRNA Spike
protein
has been detected in the brain and the
Heart of a dead man
this is a case report published in
vaccines which is a really top
well-respected Journal
quote I'm quoting from the report the
findings corroborate previous reports of
encephalitis and myocarditis caused by
gene-based covid-19 vaccines so what do
we take away from this one
the vaccines cause myocarditis we
already knew that well initially we were
told that's horrible scientific
misinformation there was a big big
banner warning every time you would talk
about this on the video sometimes they
would take my shows down for saying
things like this this is probably going
to put a banner on YouTube right now but
nevertheless the CDC now admits that the
coveted vaccines do cause in some cases
at least myocarditis apparently they
cause Encephalitis as well
so problems not just with the heart but
with the brain
but we were also told that the spike
proteins remained localized we were also
told the way these mRNA vaccines work is
they go in and you get this little shot
and then your body produces Spike
proteins to kind of mimic the covid
virus and this is supposed to give you
an immunity to the virus and it's
actually supposed to stop you from
getting the virus which is what Biden
and fauci and wolensky the CDC director
all told us and then that didn't happen
at all so then they had to change their
story entirely but anyway that was the
theory of what it was going to do but
they said don't worry these Spike
proteins that are being produced they're
not going to go all over your body
they're not going to end up in your
ovaries they're not going to end up in
your brain they're not going to end up
in your heart they're just going to stay
where they're supposed to stay and at
the time I said that's obviously BS
they're completely lying to us and they
said no that's medical misinformation
well here it is here it is they found
the spike protein there they didn't find
any other part of the covid virus there
you can't blame it on the virus they
said no we found the spike protein from
the vaccine in this dead guy's brain and
heart three weeks after we got the shot
so we were right we were right you know
I hate to say I told you so and it's not
just that I told you so you told lots of
other people so as well
we were right and yet
and this gets back to what we were
talking about a little bit yesterday
nothing's going to happen to the fauces
and the wolenskies and and big Pharma
especially nothing's going to happen
these guys are totally protected
nothing's going to happen to the big
Tech social media oligarchs who censored
all of this true information a year ago
nothing's going to happen to the
politicians who downplay these risks
Nothing's Gonna they're completely
protected
legally politically
too bad because they've got the power
and now not only do they have the power
to mandate these kinds of shots
in a lot of cases still even after
courts have struck it down not only do
they have the power to encourage people
through the culture to take all these
shots even if they don't necessarily
need the shots they have the culture to
censor the information and they they
have the power to
erase some information at least or make
it much harder to find
information that was previously out
there they can they can rewrite all the
records you know it is I know the word
orwellian is overused but it is
orwellian they can rewrite the records
they can retcon the past
we were totally right though don't
forget that and speaking of being right
I've gotten a lot of flack I've gotten a
lot of flack from a lot of quarters
since the beginning of the war in
Ukraine because I have refused to
approach the issue of the war in Ukraine
as a kind of simplistic moral Crusade
with the clear good guy and the clear
bad guy and it's so totally clear even
if there were a clear good guy and a
clear bad guy it's so totally clear
exactly what we should do in this War I
my opinion on the war in Ukraine I've
gotten Flack from the people who have
the Ukraine flag in their bios because
they think I'm not sufficiently
pro-ukraine and then I've gotten Flack
from the people who are fairly
reactionary and who are actually
supporting Russia in the war and they're
saying Michael you're you're a shill for
the decadent West because you're you're
you're two pro Ukraine so I don't know
I'm too Pro Ukraine I'm not pro Ukraine
enough but you know what my opinion has
been on the war from the beginning this
is my shocking hot take
it's complicated
that's my opinion it didn't it didn't
start six months ago or eight months ago
it's it at the very least started eight
years ago
when
there was a color revolution in called
the maidon revolution in Ukraine that
ousted a pro-ukrainian leader and
installed a more pro-western leader and
we know that there was American support
for this kind of thing and we know that
that CIA officials like gluing the top
dog at the CIA landed in Ukraine not
that long after that occurred and okay
that's fine all sorts of big powerful
countries interfere in the Affairs of
all sorts of Nations and pursue their
own interests of course that's what
happens but we do know that Russia saw
that as a provocation we Russia saw the
expansion of NATO as a provocation and
so Russia used that as an opportunity to
do what it had wanted to do for a while
and exert more influence over Ukraine
and so that was a situation that America
and the West could not tolerate so
you've had this steadily escalating War
so
well everyone's been yelling at me
because I'm not sufficiently simplistic
about my view of this war turns out Elon
Musk agrees with me because Elon Musk
just tweeted Out quote Ukraine Russia
peace redo elections of annexed regions
under U.N supervision Russia leaves if
that is the will of the people Crimea
formerly part of Russia as it had been
since 1783 until khrushchev's mistake
water supply to Crimea assured Ukraine
remains neutral that is almost exactly
what I have suggested from the beginning
of this war
or it certainly certainly before the war
even broke out as a sort of way to maybe
Stave off a war
that has been largely speaking my view
and now you've got Elon Musk who
everybody seems to love he's got exactly
the same view and the reaction from some
prominent ukrainians has not been so
nice now do you want to win a McLaren or
quarter million dollars in cash I'm
talking to all the dads right now as a
father we all want what's best for our
children and their education that's why
we sometimes speak grudgingly
but still enthusiastically participate
in school fundraisers from buying
magazines to baking cookies to paying a
bunch of kids to half wash our vehicles
at the team Car Wash well what if you
could spearhead the biggest fundraiser
in your school and community's history
with less effort than a walkathon by now
you have heard of Jeremy's razors
contest for the car where you might
become the winner of Jeremy's McLaren
now sure you could add a 592 horsepower
super War to your School's bus fleet or
you could opt for the quarter million
dollar cash prize instead
you and all the other dads and moms
could do a lot of good for your kids
with that money just by reviewing a few
referring rather a few non-woke razors
imagine a quarter million dollars to
resurface the gym build a computer room
put up some Friday Night Lights right
now most of the top players in the
contest still have not hit the 10
referrals mark so the field is wide open
for you to win it all go to the
principal's office get him or her
involved just head to
jeremy'sraisers.com play to get your
referral link and get in the game
Elon Musk proposes a solution
on the Ukraine conflict
and it's a solution that would not make
Ukraine totally happy would not make
Russia totally happy but it's a solution
that he says is the probably the most
likely resolution to it anyway and will
would in fact de-escalate the war which
is which is just steadily increasing
toward now we've got people in the Press
trying to normalize the prospect of
tactical nuclear weapons being used so
Elon puts out a suggestion that I think
is extremely moderate and reasonable
there's this guy named orestovich
arrestovich who's a blue check on
Twitter and he's a retired Ukrainian
Colonel and uh intelligence officer and
he he tweets out a picture of a guy
being tortured I think it was probably a
Russian soldier or something he's
plugged he's handcuffed he's got some
wires all around him sitting in a small
chair and it's it's uh Elon musk's face
superimposed on this poor guy being held
prisoner and it just says we work
promptly
that's that's the translation we work
promptly so it's a threat
against Elon Musk saying we're going to
arrest you and probably torture you if
you suggest
any kind of moderate resolution to this
war which is not great
that's not the kind of behavior you want
to see from our allies the people that
we're funding you don't want them to
threaten to arrest and torture our
citizens okay especially someone like
Elon Musk who has helped Ukraine who has
given lots of millions and millions of
dollars worth of starlink equipment to
the ukrainians to help fight this war
kind of complicates the picture of this
war
but more importantly than that I don't
you know I'm not I'm not even paying
particularly close attention to the war
in Ukraine which despite really bubbling
up in the press and accelerating in
recent months has been going on for
years now and there's been some kind of
conflict between Ukraine and Russia for
about a thousand years now so I I'm not
paying granular attention to it however
I have to I wish I had my Nostradamus
hat in my desk right now we were talking
about this what yesterday
and two days ago
the idea that
corporations now
can wage war
Ian bremmer very well respected foreign
policy writer
he said that specifically with regard to
the war in Ukraine corporations are
becoming literal belligerents in the war
Google gigantic corporations can play a
role in the war
and he referred to Elon Musk
specifically but then the hazard here of
course is that if corporations and CEOs
can become literal belligerents in the
war then they become literal Targets in
the war
just as this Ukrainian military blue
check dude proved because he says yeah
you're a Target Elon Musk we're going to
arrest you if you keep suggesting that
we wind this war down right now
along lines that we don't favor or that
I don't favor
that's what he's saying he's saying your
you corporations are going to become a
Target so what do we do then
what do we do then if the corporations
can literally wage the war become the
targets of the war hard military targets
China's looking at American Americans as
soft and hard American corporations as
hard as often military targets too
what does that mean and if the
corporations can make the policies about
the war and if the corporations can
censor people willy-nilly as they've
censored this show very often in the
Public Square what does that mean it
means the corporations are the
government
that's what it means it means that we've
privatized ourselves
all the way out of self-government
and it wasn't just the Liberals that did
that it was the conservatives who did
that too and conservatives did that with
some good reason in the latter part of
the 20th century the conservatives
wanted to to revive the economy the
conservatives wanted to draw a clear
distinction between us and the west and
the Communists in the Soviet Union and
so we we moved toward an intense
campaign of privatization
well that's all well and good but if you
privatize too much well then you've just
privatized away your whole government
and now you've got people who are even
who are frankly just as bureaucratic as
the Deep State we said we we only talk
about the bureaucracy of the government
we never have you ever tried to call and
change your cell phone plan do you call
a t or Verizon or something I'd rather
deal with the DMV than I would than I
would deal with at T and Verizon but
those are private companies what about
the airlines so no those are those are
private companies what about I don't
know even just
Walmart or something you know you you
call these companies you end up in this
business oh my gosh a bank oh calling
the bank it's the that's the worst
bureaucracy I've ever dealt with
that's way worse than the DMV so it's
not as though bureaucracy is just a
problem with the government it's a
problem of privatization too the only
difference is that a lot of times when
you give your government away to the
corporations the corporations are even
less accountable to you than Washington
is and that's damning with faint praise
because Washington's barely accountable
at all
but that be so then where is the line
where do you draw the line again it goes
back to my unsatisfying answer on the
Ukraine war and Elon musk's identical
unsatisfying answer on the Ukraine war
but it's but it's it's it is the normal
response I think it's the response that
the vast majority of people would
understand if if they're not political
Eggheads who are refreshing the crazy
political blogs all day long they would
realize that we need Prudence
how do you decide the the limits between
the government and the private sector
and the limits to privatization how do
you decide Prudence you you be
reasonable be normal that's how you
decide how do we decide exactly how to
resolve this war in Ukraine oh the first
major war in Europe since World War II a
war that has already had threats on both
sides to go nuclear how do you resolve
that delicately and carefully and you
use your prudence and you be normal
goodness gracious me
goodness gracious me ideologues are
going to have a lot of trouble with that
answer but that's that's what you do of
course that's what you do speaking of
private interests taking over our
government
another Told You So moment
there's a report out now that the libs
worked with the feds
through
state-backed but still technically kind
of private means to rig the election as
we've said for a long time there's
probably going to be another warning
Banner because I said that this this
episode today is going to have what like
seven warning banners under it on
YouTube I don't know if they have the
the technological infrastructure to put
that many warning banners
this report just came out there's a
coalition of ngos and sort of non-profit
organizations and academic institutions
and a private company that worked with
arms of the federal government
and with Democrat activist organizations
to censor news websites in the run-up to
2020.
they also plan to do that again in 2022
how did they do it do you think they
censored the libs just the same as they
send through the conservatives of course
not
they all teamed up the government and
the academy and private business and the
non-profit organizations that are
usually just the enforcement wing of the
American liberal Empire they all teamed
up to rig the election against the
conservatives great report by alum
bukhari in Alam bakari I don't know why
I called I actually really like the guy
and he's a friend of mine but Alan
bakari uh has a great report I suggest
you read it at Breitbart it's called the
election Integrity partnership
and this is made up of the Stanford
internet Observatory the University of
Washington Center for an informed public
the Atlantic council's digital forensic
research lab and Graphica a social media
analytics company and then it teams up
with things like common cause in the
NAACP which are really just front groups
for the Democrat Party teamed up with
the Department of Homeland Security and
the state department the whole point of
it was to censor conservatives on
Twitter and to censor conservatives on
Facebook and Google just the whole
social media platform we're talking
about the New York Post Epoch times
Charlie Kirk Tom fit and Jack besobic
who I was with last night Mark Levin
James O'Keefe Sean Hannity the list goes
on and on and on Donald Trump Eric Trump
Donald Trump Jr and they and they
flagged these posts and sometimes they
delete the posts and sometimes they just
put a little warning label on it
according to this report that came out
the EIP the election Integrity project
right which is just the sensor the
conservatives project was was pretty
successful
in 21 of cases the the social media
platforms labeled content identified by
this group as potentially misleading and
they flagged it and so you got to really
watch out for this then in 13 of cases
they just removed the content from the
platforms it's very very successful
stuff
who elected these people who elected
common cause in the NAACP in the
Stanford group and who I didn't elect
these people who elected Mark Zuckerberg
who elected Jack Dorsey who elected
Google
no nobody
but this is the way our government is
run now they just don't call it a
government
but if my rights are being taken away if
my traditions and my way of life is
being taken away by some woke Unholy
Alliance of Corporations and non-profits
it doesn't make me feel better because I
said well at least it's not the
government that's doing it no in a way
it is the government the people who
govern are the government
now speaking of a rules-based order
this week I was uh I was playing Mr Matt
Walsh at a game of fantasy football and
we made a little bet beforehand
and the BET what we the BET was that
whoever whoever
loses you know has to do certain things
right and so Matt said you can go back
to Matt's uh member block and that said
that if he loses he would have to call
me Sweet Daddy Knowles I would have to
take his title uh in in perpetuity until
I beat until he beats me again at
Fantasy Football and if I lose I would
have to eat some disgusting sort of you
know food or something that the audience
picks now it would appear
not only is uh Joe Biden identifying as
a Puerto Rican Matt Walsh is identifying
as Welsh because he's trying to Welch on
his bet
Jake says Matt what did you and Michael
decide for your bet yeah we talked about
this in the in the members block on
Friday uh we're gonna have because we're
facing off against each other for
fantasy football this week we were
trying to figure out what our bet would
be so the loser would have to do
something
um and we never decided on it so I don't
think we ever decided what the bet is
which is good because I believe I lost
and we never decided on what the bed is
I don't have to do anything I'm off the
hook he's off the hook we didn't we
never made it bet is that true is that
true producers that's not what I saw in
the member block
I think we need to go back to his tape
uh and I think what all of you need to
do all of you Faithful listeners out
there you need to tweet at Mount Walsh
and you need to get him to start calling
me by my properly well-earned
hard-fought title Sweet Daddy Knowles
that's what I am now that's my title I
didn't ask for that title
I earned that title that title was given
to me because I triumphed in the fantasy
football battle so I learned this
morning when I came into work so make
sure you check that out
it's really it's crooked is Matt is
crooked if he's not gonna make good on
his bet
speaking of crooked plans
crooked plans to reorder the political
system
it's a great a great boast just came out
from a Democrat voter mobilization
specialist
his name is Antonio aralano he's a blue
check on Twitter
he says
quote
new U.S Census Bureau data indicates
that Hispanic Texans are now the state's
largest demographic group
Latinos can turn Texas blue
okay do you see what he's saying he's
saying that
the more Latinos there are in Texas the
greater the chance that Texas will
become a Democrat state
and because the Democrats are flooding
Texas with Latinos intentionally by
opening up the borders this is really
good news for Democrats and the Census
Bureau data reflect that
as they show that Hispanic Texans are
now the largest demo group in the state
great news we're about to go Blue
this Echoes something Joe Biden said at
the Hispanic heritage reception he said
think about it no joke
when when in American history has there
been a circumstance where one ethnicity
has the potential to make such a
profound impact on a country
26 of every single child
uh who's in school today speaks Spanish
we've had large waves of immigration
before but the thing is you just have
enormous opportunity to make this
country so much better I really mean it
as my father would say let's go get him
come on Jack let's go get him
so what's he saying he's saying look
we've had big migration before but never
like this and it's all the Latinos
and that's really going to help our
political agenda it's going to make the
country better by which we mean it's
going to make the country more Democrat
it's going to make the country more
liberal it's going to make the country
more leftist
kind of sounds to me
and I don't want to
kind of sense to me like it's like a
theory
that if you replace
the the population of the country with
uh Latino immigrants in a really big way
like a really large way like a really
great way
that then the Democrats will have an
enduring political Advantage what could
we call this Theory
so it's a theory that's being posited by
well-known established Democrats not
just Democrat strategists but even the
president himself it's a theory being
advanced
about how if there were some sort of
great replacement
of the people in America
with
immigrants from Latin America
that the Democrats would get a lot more
power
can you I can't think of a name for this
Theory hmm
if you think of a name for this theory
about how there could be a great
replacement just let me know maybe in
the comments because I can't I don't
know my bro maybe I just haven't slept
very well this week but
but I think
whatever we call it that's the theory
that the Democrats are advancing now of
course
the Democrats think this is good and so
If You observe this trend the idea that
mass migration is intended to just give
the to to displace the people of the
United States and give the Democrats
more of an advantage if you if you say
that's good
then the theory is true and you are
allowed to say it but if you think
that's bad that that is happening that
that what the Democrats are saying is
happening is happening if you think
that's bad then it's not true it's false
it's a dangerous conspiracy theory and
it's got to be censored
it's the same thing you'd be saying the
same thing
but if you say
Democrats are flooding the country with
migrants to gain a political Advantage
they say okay very good yes very good
let's let's promote that post on social
media yes you're right you could say
that on the morning shows yeah but if
you say Democrats are flooding the
country with foreign Nationals to gain a
political advantage
they'd say no false you're a racist
you're a racist Nazi you're a white
supremacist bigot conspiracy tin foil at
but I just I said the same thing I just
I just changed my Cadence at the very
end
just changed it yeah yeah right that's
what makes all the difference
of things you're not allowed to say
I mentioned earlier that I was in
Delaware last night uh pinch hitting for
Candace Owens and air speech she was
supposed to give because Candace flew to
Paris to open a fashion Show with Kanye
West which is the sort of thing that
Candace does and so I didn't hear any
more details than this other than I get
a call Candace is on the tarmac she says
okay this is what's happening and that's
it okay uh then I tune in I wait for the
international trending news and I see it
the shirt that Candace and Kanye wore
is this shirt you can see the photo from
the back it says white lives matter
Candace there with a white shirt and
black Print White lives matter Kanye
there black shirt white print White
lives matter
I love it
I absolutely love it
they're getting some pushback obviously
they're getting pushed back from the
libs because the libs want to say black
lives matter
and they're getting some pushback from
the people in the middle because they
say oh you shouldn't say black lives
matter or White lives matter you should
just say all lives matter
but Kanye and Candace get it okay they
get it obviously they're being
intentionally provocative it's a fashion
show that's what you do at fashion shows
but they get the point here why would
you say White lives matter well from a
racial standpoint as long as you're
talking about black lives or all lives
or White lives
from a racial standpoint what they're
saying is
I think I don't want to speak for canvas
but this is just my interpretation of
the shirt
right now we have been told for years
that black people are marginalized and
discriminated against and insulted and
pushed to the margins of society and
that's why we need to say black lives
matter but that's not true actually
there is no legal discrimination or
systemic discrimination or really
discrimination at all certainly not at a
large scale against black people in fact
there's discrimination in favor of black
people through things like affirmative
action through certain applications of
the civil rights laws through the
culture certainly
through the popular media
the only group that you are actually
legally both legally allowed to
discriminate against and culturally
encouraged to discriminate against and
insult and Mock and push the fringes of
society the only racial group is white
people
that's what happens it's the only group
you're allowed to make fun of on TV
it's the only group white people and
Asians you're allowed to discriminate
against in college admissions and so I
don't know it's unfortunate for the
agents that they got lumped in with the
white people
but that's that's in jobs
in employment and all sorts of things
it's the white people and so there Kanye
and Candace are coming out there and
provocatively saying
putting racial issues aside they're
saying as they frequently have
The Narrative that you are being fed by
the liberal establishment is not only
false it's the opposite of true
if they're actually presenting a vision
of reality the LeBron James black black
men can't walk out their doors without
being hunted down by racist cops it's
just completely made up the only people
who are being hunted down by the
government right now because of their
identity are white conservatives they're
like Midwestern grannies who have the
audacity to raise some questions about
the 2020 election okay or pro-life
activists on the sidewalk
or parents of all Races who don't want
their kids
to be taught CRT and transgenderism in
schools
okay but then it's even more interesting
with the Kanye shirt because you
couldn't see it in the picture but on
the front of the Kanye shirt is a
picture of John Paul II
and it says we will follow your example
John Paul II
so what White lives matter on the back
John Paul II on the front and then it
hit me again maybe I'm reading too
deeply into it
but it hit me at a higher level than
just this kind of silly talk about race
is the point that Kanye is making a
little deeper than that because the pope
wears white John Paul II wore white
Benedict wore white Francis wears white
the pope wears white a white soquetto a
white mozeta a white cassack a white
that's the symbol of the Pope
and is he suggesting something a little
deeper here that when we're talking
about
White lives matter we're not just
talking about
race we're talking about
something deeper we're talking about a a
symbol not of a particular racial group
but of Purity a symbol of the soul the
symbol of the Soul after baptism and uh
a symbol of a soul wearing a you know
sort of white garment these images that
we see in Paradise we know that Kanye
has had a conversion or reversion sort
of experience to Christianity we know he
talks about religious themes a lot we
know he has an album called Jesus as
king
is there maybe a suggestion here on this
provocative shirt that actually not only
is the BLM narrative bogus we're going
to debunk and own that with facts and
logic and provocation
but the whole racial narrative is kind
of a distraction from what we should
really be talking about
which is deeper not just cultural but
actually ultimately religious because
ultimately all human conflict is
theological that that's my read on it
again I don't know I don't know that
that's what was going through Kanye's
head I actually don't really care very
often the greatest artists are not
critics of their own work very often the
greatest artists don't even consciously
know what they are doing and this has
been written about going all the way
back to ancient Greece the idea that the
artists are just sort of receiving
inspiration from the muses and then
they're just doing stuff and the reason
there's a difference between artists and
critics is because very often the
artists couldn't even articulate exactly
what they're doing they're producing the
art and it's up to the critics to
interpret that sort of Art
speaking of lives mattering speaking
speaking of a popular disregard for
human life
new details are emerging and I mentioned
this a few days ago maybe last week this
shooting of the 84 year old pro-life
lady in Michigan this retired nurse Joan
Jacobson
and shot by this uh crazy man a 74 year
old guy named Richard Harvey who says he
fired off a warning shot from his 22
caliber rifle when he heard his wife
arguing with his pro-life canvasser lady
and then he says he tried to push away
Jacobson's clipboard and said he
accidentally shot her in the front of
her shoulder accidentally fires a
warning shot he knows the gun is loaded
he's brandishing his gun and pushing
this 84 year old lady away and shoots
her in the shoulder
and she says I do think that he knew
what he was doing she says I think it
was intentional this woman is 120 pounds
and five feet tall
she says she didn't refuse to leave
their property when they asked she says
she never she didn't threaten anybody or
anything like that
certainly though there is no reason to
be brandishing a gun at an 84 year old
woman who's five feet tall
ever even even if she's coming at you
with a hammer okay there's no reason to
be to have a gun certainly not a loaded
gun and a shooter so why do I bring this
up because there was you want to make
sure you're getting the full story here
we do we still don't really know the
full story but
what we do know is as the full story is
coming out it is continuing to look
terrible for this guy
and and the way you know this by the way
is that the left-wing media are not
covering the story if the story really
were you know this awful woman was
threatening them and you'd be hearing
about it from the media but you're
seeing the media cover up this story and
so as the details come out yeah maybe
there's some complication here maybe the
maybe the pro-life lady was arguing with
the well no I'm not even sure that
that's the case
but as the details come out
we continue to look right okay right and
right and right and right I do think
people
are starting to notice that whether they
can take that noticing
and take that desire
and channel it into better government
that remains to be seen
the rest of the show is continuing now
you do not want to miss it
if you are not a member click the link
in the description and join us we have a
great interview coming up
it's with Michael schellenberger Michael
schellenberger is a really really
important voice
on environmental issues and Michael
schellenberger is is shedding some light
on what I think are not only the
ludicrous but downright offensive
Democrat claims about hurricane Ian and
and all the destruction down in Florida
which they they blame on global warming
and those mean old conservatives who
don't want to recycle or whatever Drive
Teslas and uh Schellenberg brings a
little bit of science to that so we will
get to him in just one second see over
the member block
[Music]
foreign